por aquí tengo unos problemas de ejemplo
de la sección de vectores equivalentes
de la canaca de min
así que trabajemos con ellos y como
siempre pausa el vídeo y ver si puedes
resolverlos por tu cuenta
muy bien el primero de ellos dice son
equivalentes el vector y el vector w y
bueno por aquí puedes ver al vector
y por aquí tengo al vector w y recuerda
un vector está formado por una magnitud
y una dirección
ahora bien dos vectores son equivalentes
si tienen la misma magnitud y la misma
dirección
así que si vemos estos dos bueno pues
claramente están apuntando en una
dirección diferente el vector o este de
azul está apuntando en dirección sureste
mientras que el vector w está apuntando
en dirección suroeste así que en
definitiva no son equivalentes puedo ya
cancelar esta opción no son equivalentes
y esto fue porque tienen tienen distinta
dirección tienen distinta dirección
ahora bien vamos a fijarnos también en
su magnitud y vamos a ver si tienen la
misma magnitud porque a ojo de buen
cubero parece que si la tienen pero
vamos a verificarlo y para eso voy a
empezar en el punto inicial del vector 1
y me voy a fijar en cuanto me muevo en
dirección x
bueno pues observa que vamos de menos 8
hasta menos 3 eso quiere decir que
nuestro cambio en x va a ser de 5 delta
de x va a ser igual a 5 porque pasamos
de menos 8 a menos 3 o dicho de otra
manera la magnitud de la componente x es
5 o positivo y bueno veamos qué pasa con
la componente james y para que veas qué
pasa con la componente y bueno pues
observa que pasamos de menos 2 hasta
menos 8 por lo tanto voy a decir que el
cambio y
va a ser igual a menos 6 ok y ahora
pensemos qué pasa con este vector w cuál
es mi cambio en x
bueno pues observa qué va a pasar lo
siguiente vamos a cambiar desde x igual
a 8 hasta x igual a 3 por lo tanto mi
cambio en x base de menos 5 porque vamos
hacia la izquierda me cambio el x va a
ser igual a menos 5 y cuál es mi cambio
el jem
bueno pues observa lo siguiente vamos a
ir desde el valor de 8 hasta el valor de
2 lo que quiere decir que me cambió el
james va a ser también de menos 6 me
cambio en james va a ser también de
menos 6 y bueno ya que sabemos los
cambios en x y james podemos averiguar
cuáles son las magnitudes de los
respectivos vectores w
así que vamos a pensar en la magnitud de
que algunas veces se escribe así la
magnitud del vector
o bueno también se puede escribe así con
doble barra la magnitud del vector y
esta va a ser igual a quien y observa
que es la hipotenusa de este triángulo
rectángulo entonces va a ser la raíz
cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de 5 al
cuadrado más menos 6 al cuadrado y bueno
5 al cuadrado es 25 y menos 6 al
cuadrado es 36 25 36 y bueno esto va a
ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de quien 25
36 es 61 de lujo ahora que hay de este
vector w
nuestro vector w tiene como magnitud y
de hecho me gusta más usar la doble
barra nuestro vector w tiene como
magnitud la raíz cuadrada de quien bueno
primero tenemos menos 5 al cuadrado pero
menos 5 al cuadrados 25 25
- 6 al cuadrado pero menos 6 al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 36 y entonces observa
que estamos llegando al mismo valor de
acá arriba la magnitud de w va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 61 y ahora
si observa que tienen la misma magnitud
entonces veamos no tiene la misma
magnitud pero diferente dirección de
lujo es justo esta mi respuesta correcta
así que vamos a hacer un ejercicio más y
para eso vamos a bajar la pantalla y
vamos a hacer este que tengo aquí y dice
son equivalentes el vector u y el vector
w
y bueno en este caso si parecen bastante
equivalentes si te das cuenta y bueno lo
estoy diciendo al tanteo pero parecen
muy muy equivalentes apuntan a la misma
dirección y parece que tienen la misma
magnitud pero una vez más vamos a
verificarlo y para eso vamos a ver sus
componentes equis y si hablamos del
vector
y nos fijamos en su componente x
nos fijamos cómo cambia a partir del
punto inicial al punto final bueno pues
vamos a ver qué cambia de menos 7 hasta
4 lo que quiere decir que tenemos un
cambio en x un cambio en x de 3 muy bien
ahora vamos a fijarnos en el vector w
y también fijémonos en nuestro cambio en
x vamos a ir del valor de 2 hasta el
valor de 5 por lo tanto puedo decir que
a mi cambio en x de este vector w bueno
va a ser igual también a 3 de lujo y que
va a ser de nuestro cambio el yin bueno
pues vamos a verificarlo si nos fijamos
en nuestro cambio en y en este vector y
bueno pues observa que vamos desde el
valor de 1 hasta el valor de 6
por lo tanto me cambio en james va a ser
igual mi cambio va a ser igual a 55 y
qué pasa con este vector w
bueno pues vamos a hacerlo me cambio en
lleva desde -7 hasta menos 2 y entonces
puedo decir que me cambió en game en
este vector w
mi componente ya es igual a 5 y ahora sí
observa que nuestro cambio en x es 3 en
ambos por lo tanto es el mismo y nuestro
cambio en yemen es 5 en ambos también es
el mismo así que esto nos está diciendo
que tenemos la misma magnitud y también
la misma dirección entonces estos dos
son equivalentes si son equivalentes
ambos son equivalentes y como veremos en
un futuro podemos decir que bueno este
vector y este vector y lo puedo escribir
de la siguiente manera me voy a fijar en
sus componentes y ahora puedo ver que
sus componentes son bueno su componente
en x éste
su componente en x estrés y su
componente el yen es 5 su componente es
5 o dicho otra manera su cambio en x
estrés y su cambio engine es 5 y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que el vector w
nuestro vector w tiene las mismas
componentes por lo tanto podemos denotar
un vector según sus componentes desde el
punto inicial hasta el punto final en
donde termina nuestra flecha